the four horsewomen of our political
apocalypse Alexandria Ocasio Cortez
Ilhan Omar Rasheeda Talib and Ayanna
Presley have given themselves a new
nickname we will examine our national
suicide squad and the misguided
conservatives who are defending them
then more men beat women at women's
sports go figure
Joe Biden's campaign keeps going nowhere
and Al Green the congressman not the
singer proposes a convenient strategy to
redeem America for her original sin all
that and more I'm Michael Knowles and
this is the Michael Knowles show
[Music]
the squad is here we will examine that
Suicide Squad that National Suicide
Squad but first today's show is brought
to you by our friends at Wesley
Financial Group the company that is
helping a lot of people out there who
believed those time share lies I have
relatives who have done this if you
bought a timeshare
you know the pitch oh it's a great
investment it's a legacy for the kids
you can stay whenever you want wherever
you want except the only problem with
that is it's a total pack of lies the
ugly truth is with a timeshare you can
never tell how much it's really going to
cost or when it's going to end many
owners trying to sell their time shares
online find out the hard way it's not an
investment when they can't get a dollar
for it and with those rising annual
maintenance and assessment fees buying a
timeshare is like giving the timeshare
company a blank check for life I've had
relatives who have gotten sucked in by
these things and some of them have had a
lot of trouble getting out if you're
stuck in a timeshare nightmare go to I
cancel timeshare com tell them that I
sent you Wesley financial guarantees
they will legally get you out of your
timeshare contract permanently or you
pay nothing you've got nothing to lose
you got a whole lot to gain get your
free information telling you all about
how it works go to I cancel timeshare
com
couldn't be easier than that I cancel
timeshare com check it out stop pouring
money down to the drain to those
timeshare scammers who is the squad do
you know who the squad is Ayana Presley
who is one member of the squad has given
them that definition it's AOC Rasheeda
Talib
Ilhan Omar and Diana Presley here is
Presley giving them the nickname at a
press conference yesterday our squad is
big our squad includes any person
committed to building a more equitable
in just the world
that's the squad squad can be anybody
but really it's just those four people
and guy Benson and my pal john hirsh our
over a national review gave Ayana
presley that woman the nickname ringo
she's the Ringo of the squad and it
occurred
to me that the whole squad really does
have a lot of parallels with the Beatles
because you've got a OC who's obviously
Paul
she's the marketable one she's the pop
one you've got Ilhan Omar
she's John she's the radical she's got a
pretty weird marital history then you've
got Rasheeda Talib she's the spiritual
one she's George you know she just
meditates on calming feelings in her
case about the Holocaust
obviously in George Harrison's case it
was about sort of nicer things than that
and then you've got Ayanna Presley who
is Ringo without the likability this is
our squad and President Trump has put
all the pressure back on the squad he's
put all the pressure back on Democrats
to defend the squad late night talk show
hosts are loving the squad here is
Stephen Colbert defending them against
that mean old Donald Trump of course
Trump does not like the squad he is the
leader of the rival gang of the Klan wow
wow that is so brave a late-night
comedian calling President Trump a
racist I would say it's not just brave
it's really creative obvious I've never
heard it before it's really funny I
can't stop laughing I've doubled over as
you can see and but it more than
anything I guess it's just so courageous
to say that in our culture and it's not
just late-night comedians who are doing
even random left-wing talking heads or
summoning the courage somehow to go on
leftist news channels mainstream
television and call Donald Trump a
racist if you're supporting Trump you
are a racist at this point I'm not
afraid to say it and no one should be I
just I I was so afraid to say it because
no one's saying that out there nobody in
the mainstream media or the newspapers
or television or Hollywood or the entire
left half of American politics or
basically anyone in the culture at any
time has actually had the courage to say
Donald Trump is a racist except for that
guy that random talking head on MSNBC
and Stephen Colbert they have just
summoned such such courage on the
question of
even on the question of radicalism more
generally it might be helpful to compare
President Trump to the squad because
here's how it seems to me it seems to me
that for the last three years the left
has accused Donald Trump of supporting
racists and neo-nazis and white
nationalists and used whatever term you
want and so they've said hey Donald
Trump you need to condemn white
nationalists and bigots and then Donald
Trump has basically said okay I totally
condemn bigots here is racism is evil
and those who cause violence in its name
are criminals and thugs including the
KKK neo-nazis white supremacist and
other hate groups that are repugnant to
everything we hold dear as Americans and
I'm not talking about the neo-nazis and
the white nationalists because they
should be condemned
totally we are a nation founded on the
truth that all of us are created equal
we are equal in the eyes of our Creator
we are equal under the law and we are
equal under our Constitution those who
spread violence in the name of bigotry
strike at the very core of America how
many times do I have to reject I've
rejected David Duke rejected David Duke
I've rejected the KKK the Ku Klux Klan
from the time I'm 5 years old I rejected
them I put it on Twitter last week now I
have been asked this question so many
times I have rejected it so many times
it seems pretty clear he's rejected the
racists and the bigots and the white
nationalists and the neo knives it seems
pretty clear to me at least maybe to you
the only people that it's not clear to
are the people who are willfully
ignoring Trump's repeated for years and
years and years condemnation of racial
bigots they just don't want it to be the
case that President Trump has condemned
racial bigots because then that gets in
the way of their narrative but let's
apply this same test to the left what
happens when the right asks the
left to condemn their cooks and their
bigots president Trump did it forcefully
he's done it totally he's done it
repeatedly now watch what happens when
the right asks the squad to condemn
kook's bigots and even terrorists I
really simple question will you condemn
and Tifa for attacking a nice facility
it's very simple
will you tell Americans not to attack
violently ice facilities just say no it
would be a very simple thing to say and
it would go a long way to tell Americans
that you're not sympathetic to an Tifa
are you sympathetic just say no he's
giving her the answer just say no that's
Ayane Presley the Ringo of the squad
walking down the halls of Congress and
and this is not a hypothetical question
it's not do you condemn some
hypothetical acts of left-wing terrorism
just three days ago there was a
left-wing terrorist auntie Fang
shows up with a rifle and Explosives to
a border protection facility an ice
facility fortunately he was taken out
before he could commit the terrorist
attack but we if not for law enforcement
there would have been that terrorist
attack and this right-wing journalist
says hey just double-checking cuz you've
said some pretty weird stuff
do you Squad do you Ayane Presley
condemned left-wing terrorism not an
acknowledgment that that guy asked the
question she just keeps looking ahead
she can't give the answer
imagine if the tables were turned
imagine if a left-wing journalist were
asking that of President Trump let's say
that there were a a right-wing terrorist
attack let's say weren't even right-wing
but it were some white racist guy and
they lumped him in with the right-wing
and they say president Trump do you
condemn this terrorist attack and he
just walked down the hallway he just
walked right past them in the Rose
Garden say anything right one foot away
from them just looked straight ahead and
then his handlers say oh no we're done
here where he's not going to answer that
question
imagine the coverage that that would be
getting in the mainstream media imagine
what the New York Times would say
imagine what all the left-wing members
of Congress would say
you have an exact parallel here an
actual leftist terrorist attack from an
Tifa the guy says hey just really quick
you condemn this right she can't say it
but you know what I bet what the left
will say here is that wasn't a real
press conference that was guerrilla
journalism it was some right-wing
provocateur walking down the hallway
with her she has no accountability she
has no responsibility to answer his
questions he's got to save those
questions for a real press conference
okay so yesterday the squad holds this
press conference AOC to leave Omar and
Presley they're standing there at this
press conference and one of the
credential journalists at the press
conference that the squad is called asks
Ilhan Omar to clarify her comments about
Al Qaeda because previously we'd seen
her giggling about al-qaeda so they just
wanted to make sure hey Ilhan Omar look
people are accusing you people like that
awful Donald Trump or accusing you of
having sympathies with al-qaeda but you
you condemn al Qaeda right right
don't you Ilhan Omar you respond to some
of the president's specific claims that
you're a communist and that you're Pro
al Qaeda you might have noticed how when
he said go back to where you came from
there was an uproar through the through
all of our communities because every
single person who's brown and black at
some point in their life in this country
heard that now when he made the comment
I know that every single Muslim who has
lived in this country and across the
world has heard that comment and so I
will not dignify it with an answer what
hey Ilhan amore do you condemn al Qaeda
uh I'm gonna homina homina III won't hmm
well I won't dignify it with a response
yeah that's the ticket compare that hey
president Trump do you condemn white
nationalists yup totally condemn them
Hey Ilhan Omar do you condemn
al Qaeda which you've giggled about
before about I've been a vibe Lolo knew
I don't want to dignify that with a
response that's pretty weird that's a
weird answer it's not like Ilhan Omar
hasn't talked about al-qaeda before she
has it's just when she has she's giggled
about it we'll get to that in a second
we'll get to the misguided conservatives
who were defending them but first if you
are like me and I know you are and in
many important ways I am on the internet
all the time and so are you that means
that our precious precious sweet data
are out there for big tech companies and
hackers to suck up this is why I
recommend getting the software that I
trust to protect my online activity
expressvpn their apps use powerful
encryption to secure your data I know
what you think you think I don't need
that oh who cares nobody wants my data
listen buster
I know that you look at some pretty
weird stuff on the Internet you know I'm
talking about those websites you go into
the incognito window to look up you know
and I'm sure I'm talking about daily
wire.com I'm talking about the Michal
Knowles show weird stuff these days that
could probably get you fired from your
job it could prob'ly get you kicked out
of polite society get expressvpn it runs
in the background of your computer or
phone and then you use the internet just
like you normally would you don't even
really notice it you download the app
you click to connect wallah you are
protected
I never go online with that expressvpn
you should not either seriously guys it
costs less than seven bucks a month
comes with a 30 day money back guarantee
so there's no reason not to try it the I
get why you won't try it I get her I get
the temptation you say I don't really
care about my data I'm too lazy I'm too
cheap less than seven bucks a month the
catastrophe of identity theft the
catastrophe of having your dad elite
it's guys it's not worth it seriously
take five seconds go get expressvpn
cutting-edge technology called trusted
server you will make sure that there are
no logs of what you do online go ahead
do whatever you want to do it's time to
stop the hackers big tech companies and
Big Brother from grabbing all your data
take it back with expressvpn protect
your online activity today find out how
you can get three months free at
expressvpn dot-com / michael mi CH AE l
e x PR ESS VPN comm / michael for three
months free with
your package expressvpn calm / michael
to learn more so it's not like Ilhan
omar hasn't talked about al-qaeda before
now she's saying she won't dignify it
with a response she has talked about
al-qaeda at length on camera the
difference is when she's talked about it
on camera when she's comfortable talking
about al-qaeda she's not condemning
al-qaeda she's giggling about and so it
was it was the the thing that was
interesting in the class was every time
the the professor said okay that he sort
of like his shoulders went up and you
know you don't say America with an
intensity you don't say England with the
intensity you know you don't you don't
say the army with an intensity car
though but you say these these names
because you you want that that word to
carry weight right so she's willing to
talk about al-qaeda at length so long as
she can giggle about it and so long as
she can draw a moral equivalence between
al-qaeda and the United States and the
US Army and England then she can talk
about al-qaeda and she's all smiles but
when someone watches that and says gosh
you are you are you seriously drawing a
moral equivalence between al-qaeda and
the United States are you are you
giggling a better do you have some kind
of sympathy for al-qaeda then she says I
won't dignify that with a response
these are terrible people the squad they
are terrible terrible people
they champion terrorists they literally
champion terrorists al Han Omar Rasheeda
Talib I mean even I on oppress he won't
even answer the question about aunt Eva
walking down the street these are
members of Congress who have asked for
leniency for terrorists who have tried
to go and join Isis these are bad people
they champion vile ideologies they
openly revile our country they compare
the country to Nazi Germany these are
terrible people and this brings me to my
message for conservatives if you are
defending the squad
you are the problem there is a real
sense out there that some conservatives
give greater benefit of the doubt
greater grace to the squad than to
President Trump there is a real sense
out there that in an effort to seem
broad-minded and liberal and
understanding and modern that some
conservatives give greater deference to
people who openly despise this country
than to people who love this country
specifically on the immigration question
there is a sense out there that some
conservatives give greater deference
give greater grace to people who we have
allowed to come into this country then
to native-born Americans and this brings
me to a piece that was a National Review
yesterday just yesterday David French
summed up this last point in the
National Review and I should point out
but anytime you bring up David in the
era of the conservative debates and
David for an Chisholm you have to point
out whether you like David or don't like
David and I do I like the guy you know
in some quarters these days French is a
bad word I guess actually French is
always a bad word but but David French
specifically has become a bad term and I
like David French I respect what he's
done in his career
I respect much of what he has to say but
he is dead wrong here here is what he
said it was in a piece called native
born in rates gives you a sense of where
this is going David lays out the case
for why we should basically prefer
immigrants to native-born Americans for
white immigrants basically are better
than native-born Americans now I think
they've actually changed the title on
this piece I don't know if it's that was
just some editorial decision to
elucidate what it was saying or because
there was blowback I think the new
headline is Trump's tweets were
malicious and Republicans silence is
deafening regardless of what the title
is at the moment he opens the piece by
calling President Trump a racist for his
2016 comments about that Judge of
Mexican descent he says the fact that
Trump said he couldn't get a fair shake
from this judge because he was of
Mexican descent
is evidence that Trump is a
vile racist David French never points
out here that the judge that President
Trump was talking about is a member of a
racist organization called the San Diego
la raza Lawyers Association la raza
meaning the race coming from a 1920s
Mexican essay called la raza cosmic ax
which says that Hispanics are racially
superior to every other race doesn't
mention that when you have that context
I think it at least gives President
Trump a little bit of cover here he's
not saying all Mexicans are evil no
Mexican could give me a fair shake but
that judge in particular not just by
virtue of his heritage of course but by
virtue of his association in a racist
organization maybe won't give him a fair
shake on the question of illegal
immigration doesn't doesn't mention that
then David a tax President Trump for
dodging the draft this is what he writes
quote there is something especially
gross about a man who is too timid even
to face the draft during his own
generations war now presuming to define
how Americans seek to reform their
government he is the last person to be
the arbiter of patriotism or national
loyalty now my problem with this line is
not that David's hitting French for
heard that David is hitting Trump for
dodging the draft fair enough hit if you
want to do it a lot of people in Trump's
generation dodged the draft but
perfectly fair attack to go after him
for that my issue is that he describes
the squad as Americans seeking to reform
their own government is that that's
really how we're gonna define these
people not terrorists apologists not
bitter anti Americans who equate their
country with Nazi Germany that's not the
defining feature it's just Americans who
seek to reform their government there's
no difference between Ilhan Omar and say
damn Crenshaw there's no difference
between Ilhan Omar Rasheeda Talib AOC
and your conservative activists in the
street the tax reform guys there's no
difference I think there is a difference
and I think it's the particular
wickedness of the ideologies and and the
criminals that are being defend
by the squad that that makes that
distinction then David gets to the main
thrust of his argument quote I believe
that Ilhan Omar is a toxic presence in
American politics okay so far we agree
her critiques are deeply misguided but
she should temper her critiques because
they're wrong not because she's an
immigrant the blessings of liberty
accrue to all Americans including
immigrants and while all Americans
should be deeply grateful for their
freedoms and for American opportunity
it's a simple fact that immigrant
citizens have actually done something to
earn their status they've often migrated
here at great personal cost learned a
new language built a life in a new land
passed a test
most Americans can't pass and then swore
an oath that most Americans have never
sworn by contrast what must natural-born
citizens do to earn their citizenship
survive labor and delivery that's it is
anything natural-born citizens should
exercise the most gratitude what did we
do to earn our Liberty this is
profoundly wrong but it does express a
certain view that has become popular on
the right view the immigrants they're
better than us we're terrible where were
the worst people on earth we Americans
we've caused all the problems and where
everyone else is better than us that's
that's not exactly what David's saying
but that's the sense I think that's
being conveyed the point he's making is
that immigrants don't really owe a
special debt of gratitude to this
country if anything the native-born
Americans do completely wrong
immigrants owe a special debt of
gratitude this was true when my
immigrant ancestors came here and it is
true today Charlie cook actually a
National Review made this this very
point in a response column immigrants do
owe a very special debt of gratitude
America is a country America is a
country that is founded in part on ideas
but America is not just an idea it's not
just an abstraction floating somewhere
in the atmosphere pervading the entire
world it's a country America has laws
America
as traditions and America has citizens
who are more entitled to America than
anyone else not everybody is entitled to
America her citizens are some people in
the world are Americans some people are
not not everyone is entitled to America
we have the most generous immigration
system in the world most people have no
idea how generous it is we take in well
over a million people a year legally
through immigration that's in addition
to what another million people we take
illegally we've got 3,000 people per day
pouring into this country there's no
second place we take in so many people
per year that number has skyrocketed by
the way since the 1960s when Democrats
following the leadership of Ted Kennedy
changed our immigration laws we now have
the highest foreign-born percentage of
the population that we've had since the
1890s pretty generous maybe a thank you
to native-born Americans is in order we
don't need to take in all of those
immigrants it's our country we can do
whatever we want with it
every other country gets to decide who
comes in and guess what all those other
countries take in barely any immigrants
Germany is number two and they take in a
fraction of what we take in virtually
every other country just that doesn't
take that many people we choose to take
those people in they should be
exceedingly grateful I expect to thank
you note part of David's mistake is that
he abstracts America out of existence
when my I guess would be my
great-grandfather came here from Italy
he kissed the ground that everyone was
walking on he loved this country my
Italian ancestors a you know half of my
family came here basically on the
Mayflower and then the other half came
on a sardine boat somewhere in the
19-teens and 1920s and I've never met
more patriotic people than my Italian
ancestors they wore american flag pins
they waved the American flag they would
never let it touch the ground they made
sure to learn English they did their
damndest to learn English as well they
should that's expected of them because
they're being welcomed in to the country
it's an America's not just some
abstraction it's a real place and it
requires real acts of charity to allow
immigrants to
in where David goes wrong is in the
etiology of it all just focusing so much
on ideology he writes the blessings of
liberty accrue to all Americans what did
we do to earn our Liberty as though
America were just this one word Liberty
this totally abstract concept that means
many things to many different people
many things around the world that it
means one thing in an American context
it means a very different thing let's
say in a French context pun intended but
I mean the country France means another
thing in a Japanese context America is
more than just some ideological
intuition or definition of Liberty
it's our institutions it's our history
it's our material blessings we're the
most materially prosperous country in
the history of the world
it's our substantial religious zeal even
now as religion is fading away from
America we're still more religious than
the rest of the Western world by a long
shot
it's our common bonds to each other it's
our symbols it's the American flag most
of all it's our people the country is
our people more than geography more than
buildings more than even our legal
documents the country is our people
we'll explain what this means for our
politics for the suicide squad then
we'll get to a little gender ideology
men keep beating women in women's sports
we'll get to Joe Biden we'll get to so
much more but you've got to go to daily
wire.com by the way be sure to tune in
tomorrow July 17th at 4 p.m. Pacific 7
p.m. Eastern for our latest episode of
daily wire backstage join me Ben Shapiro
Andrew Klavan and the daily wire
god-king Jeremy boring as we drink
delicious whiskey smoke lovely stogies
and chop up the latest insanity in pop
culture and politics insights and laughs
will abound that is tomorrow 4 p.m.
Pacific 7 p.m. Eastern for the best
round table talk in politics go to Daly
wire.com we got a lot more coming up
we'll be right back
the country is more than geography it's
more than buildings it's more even than
legal documents it's the people and
here's how I can prove that because you
can have the geography you can have the
buildings even and you can have the
legal documents and if you have no
people you have no country actually
there are plenty of ancient
civilizations where we still have most
of their buildings we have their
geography obviously and we have their
legal documents but there's no people
and so the civilization is gone they no
longer exist here's another example we
just celebrated the 4th of July how did
you celebrate the 4th of July did you go
into your innermost room and sit with
the lights off and close your eyes and
just meditate on some totally abstracted
concept of Liberty that's how you
celebrated right now it doesn't sound
like a fun 4th of July probably you went
to the fireworks and ate hot dogs and
hamburgers and you watched baseball
America's national pastime and you had a
beer you drank some American beer and
you watch tanks actual real tanks parade
down our actual real National Mall in
our actual real national capital which
exists somewhere we're a real country
we're very welcoming to people from
other countries that is an act of
charity and the people who come here
Ilhan Omar chief among them should
respond to that charity with gratitude
she should express that gratitude
through a love of country not
denigrating the country not talking
about how awful the country is not
laughing and giggling about Al Qaeda not
comparing the United States to terrorist
organizations not like AOC comparing the
United States to Nazi Germany they
should love the country and we shouldn't
welcome people here who don't love the
country there's nothing unamerican about
saying that that's my rant is over on
that topic I've had enough of the squad
right now we should talk about things
that really matter
not the integrity of our country our
political institutions the more
important topics like women's sports
there's a story out of New Zealand a
gender-confused man there took home
multiple gold medals in women's
weightlifting at the 2019 Pacific Games
in Samoa this is Laurel Hubbard formerly
Gavin Hubbard
who won two gold medals in a silver
three heavyweight categories this guy
somehow managed to win them all I wonder
why because he's a man obviously this is
not the first time we've heard about
this Madeleine Kern's actually another
national review writer was writing in
the net The Wall Street Journal over the
weekend and had a piece out on gender
confused men beating out female high
school athletes at track meets very good
piece I recommend checking it out so I
think I tweeted this out and then this
weirdo named Jack turbine who's a
freelance writer for the New York Times
and he's a child psychiatry resident
from Harvard Medical School tells you
everything you need to know about
Harvard Medical School called Maddie's
piece on transgender athletes bigoted
that's what the left is saying now the
left is now saying that if you don't let
men beat women in sports you're a bigot
and there's a real irony here in the
whole gender ideology movement is is you
have a woman writing in the Wall Street
Journal about how we should preserve
women's sports and then you have a man
coming in and saying that it's bigoted
to preserve women's sports that men
should be allowed to beat women that's
what it comes down to and this is what
the left does the left goes and says
that if you defend women's locker rooms
women's bathrooms women's sports any
separate place for women to have on
their own all their own to compete and
do whatever they want if you defend that
you're a bigot and the right makes a
mistake because we don't refer to the
people who say that as misogynists which
is what they are he sent out the tweet
bigoted writer in the Wall Street
Journal defends women's sports we should
say misogynist writer in the New York
Times opposes women's sports I I pointed
out to this guy how stupid his opinion
was and he had no argument so what he
did is he accused me of being obsessed
with women's sports I can assure you I
have never watched a single women's
sporting event from start to finish in
my entire life I don't watch a whole lot
of sporting events anyway and I
certainly don't watch women's sporting
events like be a WNBA or something just
not my cup of tea I don't know everybody
has their thing that's not mine
but this is what the culture warrior
left always does
they always Gaslight us on this they
radically redefine some very basic
aspect of our culture they radically
redefined sports they radically redefine
gender and they radically redefined
bathrooms that radically redefine
marriage and then some of us object to
that we said yeah you know maybe we
shouldn't just completely redefine sex
and they say you're obsessed
you're totally obsessing over it no
we're not obsessing over anything the
left is the aggressor in the culture
wars
we're the ones saying maybe your ideas
are a little crazy and weird maybe we
shouldn't buy into them and they say
you're obsessing when they say that
that's how you know that you're you're
getting under their skin because the way
that the left proceeds to dominate the
culture is slowly and steadily and they
they almost pretend that they're not
doing it I mean now we are told if you
believe in the definition of marriage
that President Barack Obama held as late
as 2012 you're a bigot that was seven
years ago that was very recently now
we're told if you believe that a man is
not a woman you are a bigot you are not
welcome into polite society this was an
opinion that was held by everybody from
the beginning of time until like five
seconds ago and now if you tweet at men
are not women you can be banned from
Twitter Twitter has said that they can
permanently suspend you for it that's
how fast they move and if you come out
and you say gosh maybe we should think
about this guy's
maybe maybe every civilization for all
of human history everywhere was on to
something when they said that men and
women are different maybe every origin
story of our species which begins with
the sexual difference between men and
women maybe I don't know maybe they
weren't just completely crazy
they say you're obsessed give it up stop
it it's not a big deal that's what they
say it's not a big deal well if it's not
a big deal let women have their own
sports if it's not you're right I don't
think it's a big deal to let women have
their own sports you on the Left you're
the ones making this a big deal so fine
let them have their
sports let them have their own locker
rooms let them have their own bathrooms
back off women exist get over it weirdos
but they won't do that they can't back
off because this is part of the
aggression of the culture wars this is
part of the I mean it's an irony because
of all people I'm the one now defending
women's sports but I guess politics
makes strange bedfellows and you are
going to see within the next few years
women's sports will not be permitted to
exist this will make it all the way up
to the Olympics you're you're already
seeing that happen now and the question
is when will feminists when will women
generally when will the fairer sex rise
up and say no stop it you weirdo men who
write in the New York Times and tell us
that we're not allowed to have our own
sports stop it you don't get to do that
it is misogyny it's a word that I don't
use very often but that's the only way
to describe it
speaking of totally old and antiquated
ideas like the difference between men
and women let's talk about that old and
antiquated presidential campaign run by
Joe Biden the some time frontrunner I
guess he's still the front-runner but he
seems to be going nowhere fast so he was
recently asked what his health care plan
would be I kid you not the gaffe machine
the greatest gaffur in the history of
American politics comes out and tells
the people that his health care plan is
that if you like your doctor you can
keep your doctor where have we heard
that before here is how many of you have
when you were working like your and you
may still be working many of you how
many of you like your employer based
health care did you think it was
adequate now if I come along and say
finish you can't have it any more
well that's what Medicare for all does
you cannot put have it period
number one there's a hiatus but in
between by the way how long it's going
to take so idly people the option if you
like your health care plan and your
employer based plan you can keep it if
in fact you have private insurance you
can keep it oh yeah is that right what
was it that a very wise man once said
fool me once shame on you fool me
the point is you're not gonna fool me
again I think that was george w bush who
said that and he was absolutely right
Joe Biden Joe Biden has been dreaming
about being president since I think the
1820s he's been a part of American
public life since the 1970s he's run for
president now almost continuously since
1988 got kicked out in 88 ran again in
2008 got picked to be vice president cuz
obama hated hillary so much now he's
running again and in all of that time
the best that he could come up with for
his health care plan is to repeat the
PolitiFact
lie of the year that barack obama said
cost obama and the democrats a thousand
seats across the country the lie that
under left-wing health care if you like
your doctor you can keep your doctor
does he think people forgot maybe Joe
Biden just forgot but we can remind him
that's not how it works if you like your
doctor you don't get to keep your doctor
under government health care is the
government has all the power makes
perfect sense
Ronald Reagan made it clear the
government that is big enough to give
you everything you want is big enough to
take away everything that you've got let
me ask you something why do you think
these left wingers in government are so
eager to give everything away for free
to give you free health care quote
unquote to give you free money in a
straight check quote unquote to give you
free housing to give you a free
education to give you a free student
loan payments do you really think it's
just out of the goodness of their own
heart do you really think there's such
charitable wonderful people they're not
they don't give any money to charity I
mean there's study after study shows
that the left and the particularly the
elected left give us a lot less to
charity than conservatives do the reason
that they keep trying to quote-unquote
give everything away for free is because
that money equals dependency in that
dependency is power they don't care
about your healthcare plan everybody in
America can access health care
nobody gets turned away at the hospital
we have by far the greatest health care
system in the world
whenever anyone wants a complicated
surgery or any high-quality health
wherever they are on earth they come to
the United States they don't care about
the quality of your health care they
want to control your healthcare choices
and that's what happens he who pays the
piper calls the tune now what this means
politically for 2020 is that Joe Biden
has nothing I mean you'd think this guy
could come he's spent the last several
years planning his run for president and
he's got nothing he can just he can only
rehash the old failed policies of ten
years ago the Democrats broadly can't
offer anything other than free this and
free that that you haven't really heard
them articulate any serious policy
proposal anything new other than
socialism which is the oldest political
ideology of any that are being promoted
right now just more of the same old
stuff and this is why they have to just
use the invective this is why they have
to insult people and call everyone
racist and everyone's sexist and
everyone's a bigot they have to do that
because they don't have anything of
substance to say and this is now swing
back around on poor old Joe Biden I I
just see him falling we've long
predicted that Joe Biden's best day
would be his first day he just keeps
kind of slowly falling down the polls
doesn't seem like he's got a lot of
oomph a lot of stamina nothing really to
to offer to the American people and it
looks like some of these squads
supported young guns who are running for
president are more likely to take it
away from him which brings us to all of
this race baiting all of this
anti-american rhetoric brings us to the
stupidest column that I've read on the
Internet today I mean it every day it
changes this one in the Washington Post
from Al Green unfortunately not the
wonderful singer but the less than
wonderful congressman he writes about
his plan to save America from our
original sin very frequently you'll hear
slavery referred to as the original sin
of America and he has a convenient
strategy to overcome our original sin
impeach Trump that'll that'll get us
past it right won't it this is what he
writes quote this bigotry this hate
homophobia Islamophobia xenophobia is a
part of our original sin I'm just gonna
stop there for a second homophobia is a
part of the original sin Islamophobia is
a part of our I thought original sin was
slavery something tells me if you polled
every single person in the not 18th
century about what they thought of
homosexuality I bet they'd all be
homophobes ok if you asked them what
they thought about Islam I think they'd
all be easily mofos quote-unquote
actually our earliest wars were with
Muslim pirates because they were
enslaving all of our sailors so I am a
little skeptical of this to begin with
because I don't they just add phobia
phobia phobia and they they add it all
into their intersectional hierarchy of
oppression Greene goes on quote we in
the Congress of the United States of
America have an opportunity to do
something about the original sin we can
do so by simply allowing these articles
of impeachment that I will file and
bring to the floor of the House of
Representatives this month to be debated
and voted upon this is really cynical
and disgusting stuff from Al Green
because what he's saying is hey hey
everyone you should feel really guilty
about something that happened hundreds
of years ago and the only way that you
can overcome that the only way that you
can prove that you're anti-slavery is
giving me what I want
politically how disgusting how cynical
he goes on well this is our opportunity
and I beg that we would take advantage
of it and let history know that when we
had a chance to do something about the
original sin of the United States of
America the sin which caused us to have
a civil war the sin which took dr.
King's life the sin which took Abraham
Lincoln's life when we had an
opportunity to do something about the
original sin we took the opportunity and
we did which was the most honorable
thing to do and that was to impeach this
president I won't even get into the
countless grammatical and punctuation
errors in this very stupid column but I
will point out his incoherence we need
to do something to overcome the original
sin the original sin of slavery we need
to do something to overcome the original
sin which caused us to have a civil war
hmm is it not possible that
the Civil War was the United States
doing about our something about our
original sin don't you think that the
Civil War did more to end slavery in
America than impeaching Donald Trump 150
years after slavery was abolished would
do to end slavery in America something
tells me it would don't you think that
the murder of Abraham Lincoln is
something that might have tone or try to
make good for the that original sin of
slavery don't you think all of the civil
rights legislation that has been passed
all of the social maturity that has
occurred all of the racial
reconciliation that we've seen in the
United States don't you think any of
that might do something to atone for the
original sin no all of that was nothing
bloody civil war three-quarters of a
million Americans dead no that meant
nothing what we really need to do is
impeach Donald Trump and then we'll have
a tone for the original sin of slavery
right mmm something tells me that's not
gonna be good enough either
something tells me Al Green is gonna
he's whatever whatever law he once
passed next then that's gonna be the
thing that it tones for the original sin
of slavery this whole category the
original sin I find a little bit
problematic obviously this is a great
egregious moral error that was part of
the foundation of this country there
were other moral errors as well do we
not think that some of the harsh
dealings with the Native Americans is
that not the original sin is that not
maybe that's part of the original sin do
we not think that some misguided Wars
might be part of the original sin some
misguided arrangements with foreign
countries might be part of the original
sin that some of our maybe the Articles
of Confederation I don't know that
almost nearly collapsed the country
before we got our constitution was that
not part of the original sin what did
what about the 19th century what about
the 20th century what what about it when
you look at the original sin of America
you realize it's much more complicated
than just one institution or one thing
you see that sin
pervades not just the founding of the
country but but the whole country not
just the whole country but the whole
world we live in a fallen world where
there is sin and and you can never atone
for sin this is what Christianity is is
unbought grace redemption from a savior
and short of a savior a sort of God
himself becoming incarnate redeeming the
world the greatest story ever told
short of that the way that we deal in a
world of sin is with grace you know the
Lord's Prayer says forgive us our
trespasses as we forgive those who
trespass against us it's a world of
grace we have two options nationally we
can either accept grace offer grace to
one another not merely condemn some past
historical figures but recognize that we
ourselves are committing in justices and
our descendants will commit injustice
--is and history will look on us pretty
pretty poorly we kill a million babies a
year that's just one example either we
can accept grace work as best we can to
improve our lot in our country and our
our moral behavior and offer that grace
to one another we can either do that or
we can commit national suicide we can
hate our country hate ourselves hate our
countrymen hate our ideals try to do
everything we can to discourage
assimilation bring in anyone else to the
country anyone but us because of how
awful we are to fall away from our role
in the world stop believing in our
foundational principles our ideas the
ideas that we've developed over time
abandon our institutions abandon our
countrymen despise our country those are
the two options
grace or national suicide we've got a
National Suicide Squad on one side we'll
see who wins out a lot more to get to
but we'll do it tomorrow get your
mailbag questions in for Thursday in the
meantime on Michael Knowles this is the
Michael and old show see you tomorrow
[Music]
the Michael Noel's show is produced by
Rebecca dabka watts and directed by Mike
joiner executive producer Jeremy boring
senior producer Jonathan hey our
supervising producer is Mathis Glover
and our technical producer is Austin
Stevens edited by Dani D'Amico Audio is
mixed by Dylan case hair and makeup is
by Jeshua alvera and our production
assistant is Nick Sheehan the Michael
Noel's show is a daily wire production
copyright day Lee Weyer 2019 everyone is
Andrew Clavin host of the Andrew Clavin
show in politics as in poker you can
only play the cards you're dealt and we
have been dealt the race card the left
has transformed racism into a
meaningless political Trump and Trump
has trumped them back yesterday was like
the Texas Hold'em world race card
championship
can anybody win this game we'll find out
on the Andrew Clavin show